well so many of us are seeing our
utility bills going up everything from
gas and power water sewer and some may
not be able to afford those costs but
there is help thanks to funds in part
from the American Rescue act Mary Jane
beliesa joins us live with how you can
see if you might qualify for those
programs Mary Jane
we all have to use water to wash our
clothes take showers and even water the
lawn and water our plants but if you're
worried about the rising cost of your
water bill then you're not alone you may
qualify for help as part of the state's
Water and Sewer assistance program
like many others in the valley Jen
Mujica is seeing the cost of our utility
bills rise she's already reusing as much
water as she can
it usually puts out about half of that
water goes to goes down back down the
drain so I collect that in my sink and
then every time the pitcher fills up I
use it on all my containers
yuhika says she's all for teaching
others how to conserve water while she
uses a water saving program offered by
the Water District I think it's so great
I think you know more information about
it for the community would be really
helpful so this is good that you know
we're talking about it today
the State's new water and sewer
assistance program is designed to help
households with water and sewer costs
but it all depends on income if you're
eligible you'll receive a one-time
annual fixed credit paid directly to
your account it's really good because
it's for homeowners and renters you
don't have to be just a homeowner that
means the yearly payment can be as low
as 240 dollars my water bill was in the
hundreds and now it's less than 100. Don
Huff is already taking advantage of the
rebate program offered by Southern
Nevada Water Authority and is always
looking for more ways to save so I put
all Rock
Desert Landscaping
pergola my house it looks beautiful now
and hardly any water so I love it she
says government programs are a big help
just ask and speak to your family and
friends and get onto the websites and
investigate that because you never know
there's there's money out there to be
saved
now the application for the state's
Water and Sewer assistance program will
be accepted through September 30th of
2023 that's this year or until funding
runs out so apply now if you can I'm
Mary Jane Valles reporting Freight news
now
and we do have a list of eligibility
requirements in the application on our
website at 8newsnow.com